when i open my eyes it seems as though a
world appears
there's this experience of a rich world
full of objects and people with colors
and shapes textures i can feel
and also part of my conscious experience
right now is the experience of being me
of being a self of being the center
of all this ongoing experience
but really it's not that the self is
doing the experiencing the experience of
being me and the experience of the world
we're all just part of this ongoing flow
of conscious perceptions
one of the central questions in
researching consciousness is how does
the brain build this completely
convincing compelling experience of the
world around us from sensory signals
the brain is locked inside this bony
vault of the skull it's dark in there
it's silent there's no sound there's no
light
the brain is conjuring up our experience
of reality by continually making
predictions about the causes of the
sensory signals that it receives it's
not that it just reads the world out
from information coming into the eyes
it's using this information to calibrate
and update its predictions about the way
the world is
[Music]
in my research group at sussex we bring
together many different kinds of
experimental angles in trying to uncover
the brain basis of consciousness one of
our experiments for instance based on
the idea that perception is to do with
the brain's predictions about sensory
signals well what we do is we present
faces and houses let's say to a person
and we make them expect to see faces or
houses and then we can ask do people see
more quickly or more accurately
what they expect to see rather than what
they don't expect to see
and it turns out that people perceive
the expected more quickly and more
accurately than the unexpected we say
commonly that oh i'll believe it when i
see it but it's really the other way
around i'll see it when i believe it
one of the biggest mysteries for
centuries has been how consciousness
happens is puzzle thinkers for probably
thousands of years how could any
explanation in terms of mechanisms
however complicated explain the redness
of red or the sharp pain of jealousy
that's what david chalmers a philosopher
has called the hard problem of
consciousness
the history of science has repeatedly
demonstrated that things that seem
beyond explanation become explicable
there's a good historical parallel that
i think about a lot which is how we've
come to understand life it wasn't that
long ago that life seemed extremely
mysterious and perhaps beyond
explanation in terms of physics and
chemistry
that's no longer the case of course we
don't know everything about life but
it's not accompanied by this grand sense
of mystery anymore now consciousness is
not the same thing as life
but my feeling is
is if we stop treating consciousness as
one big scary mystery in search of one
big eureka moment of the solution
and follow the same strategy that
biologists followed when understanding
life the hard problem of consciousness
may dissolve
we have made a great deal of progress
with the availability of brain imaging
methods that allow us to look inside the
living human brain we've got a much
better handle for instance on the neural
fingerprints of conscious experiences
what happens in the brain when
somebody's conscious where it happens
why different kinds of brain activity go
along with consciousness so we know for
instance that not all of the brain is
involved in consciousness for example
the cerebellum which is this little
brain hanging off the back of your head
actually has three quarters of all the
neurons in your brain that does not seem
to be involved in consciousness at all
one of the projects we've been working
on in my group is to develop measures of
brain dynamics that track let's say the
difference between normal wakeful states
when you fall asleep when you go under
anesthesia and when consciousness
changes dramatically such as in the
psychedelic state one of the measures
we've developed is something called
brain complexity and it turns out that
by measuring
how
many different patterns of activity
there are in the brain how diverse its
activity is
that provides a good approximation a
good
rough measure of how conscious you are
but we can really put a number to how
conscious somebody is and that's that's
a really powerful and useful thing to be
able to do
consciousness is everything without
consciousness there's no world there's
no self there's there's nothing at all
this is
for me where the mystery of
consciousness really comes home it's not
just a deep scientific mystery it's a
deeply personal mystery it's a mystery
that matters and when i was a kid i
think like many kids there's this moment
where you wonder where was i before i
was born and then quite quickly what
happens when i die
and that leads you to think well who am
i you know what is what is this
experience of being me
where does it come from what does it
mean
these are questions that arise at an
early age and i've just been lucky
enough to to hang on to them
[Music]
you